okay hi everybody I'm so excited to be
here speaking at posit comp and I'm even
more excited that you all are sticking
around for the very last session of
[Applause]
posit so I work for the state department
of agriculture in the state of
Washington and we've collected almost
900 different soil samples from all
across the state and every single one of
those Farmers or land managers gets
their very own custom soil Health Report
and this is going to help them
understand the soil Health in their
fields and they can make decisions on
how to manage their fields based on
these reports based on this data how did
we do this we use parameterized
reporting with
CTO so maybe you don't care about soils
I've only met one person at this
conference who also works in soils so I
want to point out some other examples of
how you can use parameterized reporting
so there's examples of mapping Ocean
Floors making fiscal briefs or figuring
out who the be which state has the worst
drivers so there's all sorts of
different ways that you can use
parameterized
reports now why should you listen to me
I have zero Computer Science Background
I have no coding background but I
absolutely love automating things and I
love making beautiful products so
originally when I started at the State
Department of Agriculture I was hired as
just an environmental technician I
scooped water out of streams that would
get tested for
pesticides So eventually though I
started to teach myself some basic R uh
R data wrangling and visualization and I
applied for a data scientist job in our
soil section so I went from water
quality and field workor to soils and
data science and this is really cool
because I got to go from picking leeches
off of my boots to picking cats off of
my
keyboard so you're probably wondering
now how did I go from being a non- coder
to a data scientist and I had the the
answer is a skills test I had the
opportunity to learn something new
parameterized report Ing and demonstrate
this ability at this through this skills
test where I had to create custom soil
Health reports for 86 different
farmers and I had one week to do this I
had no idea what a parameterized report
was I was kind of freaking out I was
wondering how do I automate reports and
I sort of felt some existential dread
and I was wondering have I made made the
wrong decisions in life am I in over my
head but lucky for me the rstats
community is so amazing I was able to go
down so many different rabbit holes and
looking at YouTube videos and blog posts
and I went through a bit of tutorial
hell but that all got me to this place
where I was able to create these reports
with parameterized our markdown in one
week
so these are the reports that
essentially got me my job and got me out
of the streams and behind a computer
where I get to just chill with my cats
all day and work in case my boss is
watching
this okay so fast forward to two years
later we're in
2023 and we've switched to quto because
I went to posit comp I went to our
studio comp 2022 and learned about Corto
and was just so excited so in 2023 we
now have HTML reports where we're using
leaflet we're using plotly and now we
have these cool interactive
reports but there's some people who
would rather just have a physical piece
of paper so to make sure that our
reports are accessible to everybody we
created these Microsoft Word outputs
which I then manually converted to PDF
because I didn't want to learn lat
Tech and Microsoft Word is so easy to
make uh template reports that have just
out of the box beautiful
styling
so this talk is the very last session of
the conference I'm tired you're probably
all tired our brains are full if you
want to take a nap please feel free
because I have all the slides available
at the bitly link at the tiny URL Link
in this QR code but I'm going to have a
lot of code Snippets that I'm not going
to have time to walk through so I've
included them and you'll have to take a
look later on in the um in the
slides okay so there's a generalized
four-step
workflow um from the perspective of a
self-taught community taught our user
where I first had to learn what is
parameterized reporting so we'll go
through a bit of parameterized reporting
101 and then we're going to talk about
subsettable data and how to get our data
ready for parameterized reports and then
we'll talk about making sure that our
content is interpretable and
understandable to our readers and also
accessible so our font sizes color
contrast and for the python users in the
room the parameterized Corto reports can
also be used with the Jupiter engine as
well as the nitter engine so take a look
at your the the quto docs for the syntax
differences okay so Step One is learning
about parameterized reports so what is
it it's essentially a template report
where it's going to have placeholders
where you can then fill in um whatever
values you need so what really helped me
to think of parameter reports as
functions like really comp Lex functions
so imagine you have a quto file and
you're trying to report something um for
every single year so this function or
this template is going to take in
parameters as the function input
essentially so if you are producing all
these reports for each year instead of
going through and changing 2019 to 2020
to 2021 you're going to put in pams
dollar sign year and then that the
output of your function are going to be
these reports for every single year
without copying and pasting it's
amazing okay so for your parameterized
report you'll have a yo header which
stands for yet another markdown language
and this yo header is going to contain
your basic metadata so your title
subtitle date author that fun
information it'll also be where you
specify your format types so in our case
output to HTML and where Doc and this is
also where you're going to set your
parameters so these are key value pairs
where you're naming your parameters and
then you're also naming uh the default
value that it will
use below your emo header is going to be
your basic report
content now how do you access your
parameters when if you're working in R
Studio interactively you can run any
line or code chunk and this is going to
add this paramed object to your
environment and then because this is
just a list object you can use the
standard list notation and access these
parameters with pams dollar sign farmer
and then that would give you like Sammy
sunflower and you can also use
parameters for inline code so if you
enclose your expression and backtick R
your expression backtick it will
dynamically calculate or render whatever
your parameter is so for example we have
these are results for prams dollar sign
farmer Sammy
sunflower now how do you render the
reports so the fastest way to just
iterate over your reports
and edit and get the look and the feel
right is using the IDE and using the
render button and if you hit the little
arrow you can choose between all the
different outputs um that you've specif
speci ified in your
yaml um if you like hot keys or short
keyboard shortcuts like I do you can use
control shift K and that's super helpful
and another Nifty feature is the render
on Save option where if you have that
checked every time you save your file
it's going to render that report and
then you'll be able to see your HTML
preview update if you're rendering to
HTML and it should be noted that
the this way of rendering these reports
are going to use your default parameters
uh that you've specified in your yo and
it's also going to have the same name
and the output file location as the
input
file now you can also programmatically
render your quto files using the quto
render
function and this you would include it
you would run this in your console or in
a separate iterate R script or whatever
you want to call it and and you're going
to specify your input file your output
format type the output file name and
then your named list of
parameters and this is especially
helpful for when you want to render all
of your reports at one time so to do
this we're going to create a data frame
that has two columns and these column
names will match our CTO render
arguments the first is output unor file
and this will contain the file name with
the
extension and then execute undor prms
will have the named list of
parameters and so here's the an example
of code I'm not going to talk about but
you can check out later to get this
basic two column data frame that has the
output files and the ex the
parameters and we can use the per pwalk
function to iterate over each row of
this report data
frame and we'll just again specify the
input file name and the output format
which is going to match the um file
extension that you had in this reports
data frame and this is where the magic
happens I've heard the the term
magic being said so many times at this
conference it's simply amazing but
seriously it's pure magic so this is all
the files being knit back to back from
one function called
and you can see all the documents are
just being populated in the files paint
it is absolutely
amazing and I figured that out at about
2 in the
morning um I don't know why that was not
hidden but uh yeah I I figured that out
at 2 in the morning the day I was
supposed to turn in my skills test and I
ran into the bedroom and I woke up my
husband and I was just so shocked and
excited I yeah probably looks like
Pikachu and my
catm okay so now we're going to talk
about getting this data ready for our
parameterized reports so we're preparing
data that is subsettable and this is
just a simplified data frame where we
have our year and our farmer and these
are again our parameters and some
example data and yes thanks chat GPT for
the puny farmer
names um so you can use these params as
basic values so here we're just using
decler filter and then setting our
farmer equal to whatever that Pam's
value is so we're doing some data
wrangling here and creating a new column
called category and for each farmer that
is being the report is being rendered
for that value would be your fields for
any samples that are in the same crop it
would be same crop and then any other
project uh any other samples in the
project would just be called other
fields and this is going to come in
handy when we do our visualizations for
our
reports so now we're going to create our
content so we want to make sure that
it's easily consumed by whoever we are
sending these reports to that they're
able to understand and make decisions
based off of what you're showing
them so one way we did this was creating
these static plots and interactive plots
for HTML format but we're now using that
new category column and we're styling
each point so that it's really clear
that the uh for to the farmer which are
their fields which points are the uh
fields that are in the same crop or the
same county and then just the General
Distribution of the
project and this helps um people to
interpret their data based on comparing
it with other uh other points so we also
want to make sure that our reports are
self-contained so we want to make sure
that we are providing all the content
for our readers to really understand the
results that we're showing
them so we want to uh so we included
about 30
different soil Health measurements and
instead of including 300 lines of just
regular text and pros of what these
measurements were we can use a include
short code that's actually going to just
embed this other quto document that's
called soil Health measurements into the
parameterized parent quto file and it
makes it so easy to reuse information
across your different reports and it
shortens your your main
document and I also mean self-contained
in the more literal sense for the HTML
reports where uh we want to make sure
that we can just send the HTML file
email it whatever and then the recipient
can just open it off the bat and so to
do this we'll do an include in yaml or
we we'll do um embed resources true in
the yaml header and what this is going
to do is make sure that all the data
images Styles sheets Etc are embedded
into that file because otherwise quto is
going to give you a underscore files
folder that has all of those external
dependencies and if you send that with
your HTML file no one's going to know
what to do with it so make sure you
embed and then also make sure you're
mindful of size so if you are doing
these self-contained
reports don't make them too big that you
can't email them so just just a heads up
on
there okay and then designing for
accessibility so I already talked about
about how we created HTML reports and
PDF reports so Corto makes this really
easy by using these divs where we can
use this content visible when format is
HTML and this is really helpful when we
want to use panel tab sets for just our
HTML reports so that we don't have to
have a whole long list on our HTML file
we can have tab sets for each category
of our soil
measurements and for non-html files we
can use the content visible unless
format HTML div and now we just have our
background information and a regular
list of
definitions we also can use conditional
code evaluation where the code will only
be evaluated if the output format is met
so for example if we wanted plotly code
only for HTML or ggplot code for
anything else to do this we're going to
set an output format type in our setup
chunk using this snitter Ops snit get
function and then we can use this
outtype
variable uh value in our eval chunk
option and now we're including both of
these code chunks in our document but
only the code chunk that is has that
eval um evaluated to True um will
actually render and be included in your
report so here's some tools for by uh
styling and picking your colors and
contrast um and you would include this
in your yaml header for HTML output Word
document and these are listed in the
resources and I don't have time to talk
about the um browser developer tools but
this is here for you um to double check
your contrast ratios for your HTML
reports and what's really Nifty is if
you click on it you can actually adjust
the color
but again I don't have time so um the
end result though was um everybody gets
their very own custom decision support
tool so that's essentially what
parameterized supports can be if you
design them right and um provide all the
context that's needed to understand
those results
so um to recap we learned a little bit
of parameterized reporting
101 uh we saw that we can just use our
data that has columns for each
parameter and then we made sure that our
content is easily understandable and is
accessible to all of our
audience and now because we didn't copy
and paste we didn't do each of these
reports manually we now have time to
take a cat nap watch TV hang out or work
if my boss is watching
this okay so I promised you seven slides
of resources so I have all the resources
that well not all a curated list of
resources from my immense times of going
through all these different rabbit holes
so there's um the quto docs and
videos uh tutorials
examples
videos style sheets accessibility
tools and I would love to connect with
you over My Favorite Things cats feature
are and
Corto and I'm sure we're all feeling
like this and ready to go home thank
[Applause]
you